here's a surprise criticize meghan
markle
cnn says you must be racist
people here on the right continue to
savage
markle and her story something struck a
nerve with them
was it a multi-racial woman speaking out
against an
institutional white royal family
oh no no it's not about that well then
what is it about
what is it about then chris should know
i mean he is black
on the inside you know i'm black on the
inside
i'm sure blacks are so grateful to have
him
but hey racism is basically the only
thing left
that chris is allowed to talk about on
cnn
so we finally reached the rasp the
racism accusation
saturation point where every activity
belief or opinion
can be traced back to racism me just
pointing this out
makes me racist you hearing me say that
makes you racist
and if you deny it that's proof of
racism too
unless of course you work for cnn or
msnbc and become the accuser to enable
your own
vile commentary over at msnbc joy reid
can
freely indulge repulsive rhetoric
smearing millions of americans by
tweeting that conservatives
would trade tax cuts to openly say the
n-word
could that include her co-worker nicole
wallace how else does joy get her facts
on this stuff i mean
that's the only conservative she knows
right
then there's her smear of tim scott
gotta love the tim scott standing there
to provide the patina of diversity over
that
round of words that a basket full of
words
that's a stupid comment for it can be
applied to its user
would joy still be employed saying such
vile things
if she were white remember those
homophobic slurs she blamed on a hacker
good times so on the spectrum of slander
where being called a stupid jerk is the
most harmless and
being called a pedophile is the worst
where does
your a racist fall i'd say it's closer
to the extreme
it can ruin lives and it's delivered by
elites from their broadcasting perch of
immunity
with no accountability so as the derek
chovin case approaches and the specter
of bloodshed looms
remember who excused previous months of
violence
they could do it again and why you
deserve it
you're racist so judge i'm going to go
to you first because
you're one of the people that cuomo is
talking about
so here's the deal if everybody is being
called
racist right because it's easy it's a
low bar
barrier of entry you can just call
accuse anybody of racism and people run
away and they're scared
but it's obvious that this is damaging
to people when you
when you smear them this manner you're a
judge
is is it time to start suing people for
mischaracterizing you
people as racist if they have no
evidence at all
is that a possibility well yeah it
definitely is a possibility because
racism as it's being used today is is a
is a word that it denigrates you it
makes you less of a person it makes
people want to hate you more
especially and and by the way your
monologue greg was
excellent because you really do have to
look at where it is
in this spectrum you know pedophile is
is a crime and we all know it's a crime
race
uh racism it may or may not be a crime
depending upon
you know i fought for hate crimes in new
york i fought for hate crimes to be
enacted
i went before congress i went before the
new york state legislature
and i've done i've created a hate crimes
bureau i mean i'm the last person
but if he calls me that that is
something that is offensive and can ruin
my reputation depending upon what i want
to do with my life
so it is derogatory i believe it's
defamatory
and i think they're using it too broadly
and here's the thing
your point is excellent in that if you
keep saying that people are racist
then when something happens you can say
see i told you so these people
definitely are racist
and now the proof is in the pudding and
therefore i have the right
to defend myself or do what i have to do
but it is at the point where
uh liability is definitely an issue
hey you know juan when joy reid mentions
the patina of diversity regarding
tim scott and what i thought was a
fairly disgusting comment
doesn't she realize that anybody could
just flip that back on her
because the the accusation of tokenism
is based purely on skin color
so therefore it's a broad accusation
that anybody could use
yeah i mean look i i think you could
flip it around i mean there's no
question the thing is
that there's only one black republican
in the u.s senate and that's tim scott
uh and there's no getting away from that
uh is that his fault
but is that his fault though that he's
black
no he won in fact it's an achievement i
think he
i think he broke a barrier in terms of
especially from south carolina it's an
extraordinary
thing that he did anyway but to get back
to your larger point
you know i think the monarchy is an
institution where bloodlines are
everything great everything and so as
americans i think we can agree
that there's nothing less diverse than
the british monarchy
uh so you have to intentionally it seems
to me
look away from the reality to say that
race has nothing to do with what's going
on here
i just think it's hard to do i just
think it's implicit in what
was so news making about the fact that
uh that prince harry was marrying meghan
markle
i would agree with scott just to get
back wait i would agree okay so then i
would i think race i think that's not
it's not forced to say race is part of
this topic but anyway
the larger point is that racism is now a
part of
every topic that's why it's so
meaningless
that's my point i don't think it's every
topic but i do think that right now
around the world as we become a more
diverse society here in the united
states and even in britain
uh people are having to deal with this
in a way that they haven't before but to
get back to senator scott
as i'm saying to you i think he's an
accomplished man but he's also a man who
has said very clearly that he has been
you know profile racially profiled by
police in his life
even by capital police so it's hard
to pretend that there's no problem no
one's denied
him as okay i'm just saying so it's not
you can't just say oh that's no issue
race is not an issue
nobody said that senator scott said that
no one said so
we said the accusations and also
also you got to deal with the fact that
the republican party right now is
involved in
taking steps to limit voter turnout and
a lot of black people feel
it's intentionally aimed at them you've
got white supremacists who were involved
in the january sixth riot
so we got you know we can find flaws
with george reed's argument it was six
months
to me hold on that's not true anyway but
the bigger argument for me
is that the gop the party of lincoln has
to look in the mirror on race right now
and decide where it stands
yeah and the party of the confederacy
should probably do the same
so martha um
where do you stand on this evil racist
culture that we seem to live in
everywhere everywhere we go we are met
with racism what can we do now what is
the solution if we were all racist
you know i i just go back to chris
cuomo's comment because he says
why was it you know that people on the
right continue to savage markle and her
story
something struck a nerve was it a
multi-racial woman speaking out against
an institutional white royal family
well maybe chris cuomo but maybe it
wasn't yeah
maybe what it was was that they really
embraced her
when they met her i think they were
happy that harry had found someone he
had said quite openly that he was
looking for a wife he really wanted to
get married and have a family
so he met her you know she seemed to be
embraced she was beloved by press
on both sides of the pond but then
something happened right and over time
the feelings seemed to go against her so
the question is right you know she's now
accused of bullying people at
that that were working for her that were
helping her and so you just have to ask
yourself
no maybe it just had to do with the fact
that the relationship started to fall
apart that they
learned that she wasn't the person that
they thought she was maybe it has
nothing to do with race and you know who
said that
her father thomas markle who is a white
man who married an african-american
woman who is megan's father
he has a biracial daughter even about
the comment about the
color of the baby's skin he said maybe
it was just a stupid question
maybe the person isn't racist who said
it so
i i think you just have to peel back
that layer and ask yourself
it's a human issue not a race issue that
has arisen here
potentially yeah and the larger issue
jesse which i thought i made clear
isn't saying that there's no racism what
i'm saying is the constant
accusation of racism when you're being
critical of somebody in the media
whether it's somebody who is in who is
in royalty and a celebrity
maybe it's not always racism
it's lazy punditry greg something i'm a
little familiar with myself
i think chris cuomo is smarter than this
we get paid to tee off on people
if barack obama were white i'd still go
after obamacare
if beto o'rourke were black i'd still
make fun of his silly hand gestures
what's happening is chris chromo
probably didn't have a creative
angle for the segment that night so he
got lazy and played the race card
it's an analysis that's about skin deep
and right now they're struggling because
they don't have a lot of material now
that trump's not there
so their producers are having to put
forth stuff that doesn't really cut it
why do rich white liberals
feel like they need to see race in
everything what do they need to look for
and why when it's not there
do they need to insert it they see it in
a cpac
stage they see it in a car in a costume
in a song in a hat they see it in a
princess
they see it everywhere so why are they
doing that they're doing that
rich white liberals to keep themselves
on the top of the democratic party
and they're doing that because they need
to assuage their white guilt
and they need to go to their buddies in
the black community and say hey hey
i'm a white guy but i'm not like one of
those white guys
right those white guys aren't cool i'm
one of the cool white guys
and they get off on that the joy read
thing i'll finish here
it's like heads i win tails you lose
when you flip a coin
if the republican party's all white
they're racist and if they have a few
blacks
it's a token and still racist
very good all right